This was locker room talk, I'm not proud of
it.
We've seen him rate women on their appearance.
Let’s pretend for a moment that the biggest
headlines out of Sunday night’s
presidential debate had nothing to do with sexual assault allegations, or non-handshakes,
or threats to jail political opponents—
but instead were about policy.
In that bizarre alternative universe, what
would we actually learn?
Well, last night we learned the two exhausted
political parties have nothing much left
except critiques about how lousy the other one is.
Some of which were, to be honest, pretty good.
Including for Mr. Deplorable himself.
She talks in favor of the rebels.
She doesn't even know who the rebels are.
Look what she did in Libya with Gaddafi.
And sure enough, when the most hawkish Democrat
this side of Joe Lieberman talked about her
solutions for the war-torn Middle East, it
was a word-salad of
“safe zones” and “no-fly zones”
and wishing really hard that good things
would happen.
I hope by the time I am president, that we
will have pushed ISIS out of Iraq.
You can see the same dynamic at play with
Obamacare.
Trump rightly points out the problems:
Their method of fixing it is to go back and
ask congress for more money.
More and more money.
We have right now almost $20 trillion in debt.
And Clinton responds with boilerplate blather:
let's fix what's broken about it, but let's
not throw it away
and give it all back to the insurance companies.
So, what’s President Trump’s solution?
We have to repeal it and replace it with something,
absolutely much less expensive
and something that works.
As for Syria, it’s hard to decipher Trump’s
exact position;
except for that he definitely hasn’t talked to Mike Pence any time recently.
He and I haven't spoken and I disagree. I disagree.
I think we have to knock out ISIS.
Hillary Clinton was at her best Sunday night
when explaining why Donald Trump was not fit to be president,
a judgment with which I and
about half the Republican caucus in the Senate
at this point agree.
Donald Trump was at his best when pointing
out that the policies Clinton has supported
have not been good for the country, something
I wish more Democrats would admit.
But is there a positive case for Hillary being
fit for the White House?
Are there Trump policies that are gonna turn
this mother around?
No.
Of course not.
What were you thinking?
It's just awfully good that someone with the
temperament of Donald Trump
is not in charge of the law of our country.
Because you'd be in jail.